amherst massachusetts on a dichotomy
structure serum for the recipient
problems thanks thanks for being here
for the equation this is joint work with
Wolfgang out of our and um Emma and like
Alexandra mallu and I'm going to talk
about the resilience problem today but
actually what I'm interested in knowing
how to change your mind what is a
complete self Jim here so imagine a
world where we could selectively delete
memories from our brain and by doing
that we could change someone's belief or
opinion because it does need to be
memories could be some like information
from the brain would you be interested
in knowing how difficult it is given
that you have a specific target right I
there's a particular belief roping and
that I wanted to delete I think a lot of
people be interesting this like today
right so this is what we investigate
however as a computer scientist I'm not
going to be poking people's brains and
I'm gonna do this in a more simpler and
like ethical scenarios so I'm going to
be talking about this problem in the
database contacts so I'm going to be
thinking of the brain as databases on
the opinions and beliefs would be the
query answer and the deletion of
memories is the deletion of tuples so
more formally this is what I'm doing I'm
gonna fix a query and then I ask what is
the giving a database I'd like to know
what is the minimum number of tuples
that I delete from the database in order
to change the query answer from two to
false I'm going to be dealing in general
with like bullying Paris but I could
also think of non boolean queries and
this would be the problem of deletion
propagation if you are like familiar
with that let's just see an example of
like a query here so in this square e I
have relations v joining with relation
eight this is the dialogue notation the
like existential quantifiers are all
like implicit here and the question
would be what is the complexity of
resilient for this query if you think
about it
is it's just the edge relation in the
graph so the database could be seen as a
graph where I have V being the set of
vertices and if there is an edge there
is the top o in this relation e so the
resilience problem for this query is
actually the same thing as vertex cover
so if the query is true it means that
there is at least an edge in this
database or graph and in order to make
it false I need to get rid of all of the
edges let's put in this way you're like
all of those like assignment of values
that make the query true so I just need
to find the minimum number of vertices
to delete therefore the resilience of
this query is np-complete okay clear
from okay so first thing is that
resilience is np-complete in general
right in this talk I'm going to be
talking about a specific class of
queries which are constructive queries
without self join here we actually have
a self joint so you're not going to be
dealing with queries of this type and
what I mean by self join is that I have
a relation appear we repeated in the
square e so it's join of itself I'm
gonna call this set of deleted tuples
the contingency side and i'm also
applying this particular restriction on
the database so i have endogenous and
exogenous like tacos or tables what does
that mean so for the purposes of finding
the contingency said I'm going to just
be looking into endogenous tuples
because it might be that I don't have
access to certain tables in the database
right there are forbidden from me to
touch I can't delete anything from them
so for the purposes of the problem I
wouldn't be looking to them now that you
find the continuous that so I considered
them exogenous an insulator that's gonna
influence on how the complexity of the
problem goes so i'm going to show you
what chopper is here and start from
there i will lead us to the dichotomy
theorem so i'm going to look into the
queries actually not from the data log
like representation but i'm going to
represent them as like hypergraphs
actually do hypergraphs so
here for each relation I'll have an atom
and the variables that occur in its
relation are going to be the hyper edges
so here i have this query that you know
coincidentally we call triangle curry
and the one on the right on the right
it's called the tripod query the
question again is what is the complexity
of resilience for those queries so I'm
going to tell you right away they are
both NP complete and i'm going to show
you reductions to to prove the NP
complete zombie shove them so first i'm
going to show that the triangle / is
np-complete by a reduction from the
three sad problem so you know the drill
i have a formula with like em clauses
and i have n variables and i want to
build this database such that for a
certain k that's going to depend on the
formula if the formula is satisfiable i
will have a contingent set of up to that
size and vice versa so here let's go and
see again like look at the query the
triangle curry again and I want to find
I wanted to design this database such
that i can find this contingent set of
exactly that that size and after i
delete that gamma from the database that
I created I won't have this cold
triangles so we can think of a joint or
like an instance of an association of
these variables that make this curry
true as this color triangle where each
edge represents a top o in the database
okay I mean I want to like get rid of
all of them so first of all I'm going to
create the variable gadget so for each
variable in this formula I'm going to
create like tuples that correspond to
variables and of course if I have like
an assignment for the variables in the
formula I'm gonna meet that means I'm
gonna pick certain tuples from the
database but then I need to choose how
those tuples are going to be connected
because I want to be very careful and
like how many joins i'm going to create
because i want to make sure that i know
exactly which suppose I need to delete
so he in this case we have discolored
triangles and you see those like funny
ones they are like specific
they're in that way because we define
this gadget that such that they are
never chosen why is that because if you
if you notice the dotted like edges
participating just one join or like one
just one color like triangle and then
like as usual in order to get rid of all
the call triangles in this gadget for
each variable I need to delete either
all of the VIS or all the VI bars a sofa
but we also have to have the sessions
for each clause in the formula any
particular not just each cause i would
have liked em sessions of things like
that but i also have this other area
here that is just sort of like a petting
because as I said sometimes when you
start to include tacos you might create
joints that you didn't want so you need
to have some like kind of boyfriend so
we can actually have these values not
coinciding places that we didn't want so
we're actually making the connection
that you see after because this is just
for the variable gadget not even the
cause yet we will see that this is going
to be a little important so then we we
got we created the variable gadget so we
know what's going to happen there and
now I need to connect that to the
formula itself which I do by the causes
so if you give me a Class V V 1 or not
v2 or v3 what I'm gonna do is that I'm
going to connect certain nodes of
certain values from each of the like
gadgets for the variables so here i have
like variable 1 level 2 1 v1 v2 and v3
so i have on gadget one a particular
session which corresponds to the clause
being connected to the same area from
the gadget to and the same error from
the gadget tree and I do that by just
identifying the values so we could ask
oh but what if what happens if I
identify those values am I going to
create things that I didn't want you I'm
gonna fight that because I had those
pairings before I'm not gonna go into a
lot of details on that but trust me that
that works and hear what happens that
when i connect those I create a new
color triangle right before I had all
the skull triangle
in each variable gadget but then now I
create for each cause I call a triangle
which is a joint that needs to be killed
so this reduction gives us that if there
is a satisfying assignment for this
formula means that at least one of those
like tacos here have been chosen and
their father is no joint so if there is
my assignment I can find a continuous
out of that size if not at least ugly
outlet at least one more tap off any
questions ok so now as I said we show
that the triangle query is np-complete
let's go ahead and show that its tripod
queries also NP complete but before we
go there let's first observe that when I
look into the set of variables of Adam a
and the set of variables of autumn w or
relation w all the fibers are the core
here cadet you the same for B and see
what that gives us is that if you give
me a contingency set that contains a top
of front w I can always exchange a taco
from w for example from a wise that is
that if a particular type of let's say
w123 is on a contingency set it means
that there exists a joint one two three
so I have a typo 81 at applebees shoe
and a top of c3 so it doesn't matter if
I exchange that W by a top or from a by
but that a 1 yes sure that's really good
can you explain this
rotation a of X divided all the bases
you can think of this as like exists x y
and z such that ax + b b YC z and so you
can think of this is like a finite like
structure and that the vocab why would
be a bc w yes yes I mean given that
power we devote our God is gonna be
effects right so that's a car covers and
and all that all the free variables are
existentially home so as I was saying
any couple from data that might be the
joy can be so sexually exchanged by
someone some typos in a and I won't like
change my solution I might even improve
any terms of know if it was already
there so that means to me we say that in
that case the relation a like Adam a
dominates w meaning that for the
purposes of finding out the contingency
said I don't need to look into W it's
always better to look into a B or C
which as I mentioned before where I have
a name for that is what we call
exogenous so i can say specify initially
that a particular relation is exhausting
us but you know it might also happens
that given how the query is the relation
of exogenous anyway so if that happens
i'm going to consider that as that that
way so we can look into like the tripod
query as the same thing but then we're
considering the w relation as exogenous
and now to the proof so in here instead
of like doing a reduction from 3sat i'm
going to just reduce that you know the
triangle query the resilience of the
triangle / that you already know is
np-complete should the resilience of the
tripod query so giving a database in a
particular k i'm going to produce a deep
prime database d prime such that it's
going to have the same size of continues
inside and it's a very straightforward
but like a kind of simple reduction so
for each tuple that occurs here in our
i'm going to create a typo in a and B
and C I think not respectively as to be
in teachers
and I join all of them if they join here
right by adding the stuff going w and
what I'm claiming up doesn't not gonna
go into details of proving it but we
have the proof is that this happens so
this shows that this query the
resilience of the square is hard NP
complete so after we had those results
we thought okay what do those queries
have in common if anything in terms of
like the structure and we find out that
they actually have what we call the
triad as a as a common factor so what
triad is any set of three endogenous
tuples that's an important trade because
if it was exogenous doesn't matter for a
solution right that are like connected
pairwise connected independently what do
I mean by that so let's look into the
triangle query here so they hard to see
that you have a triad right and
basically I'm saying that I NS is
connected RNs are connected
independently from the variables that
according T and the same happens for TN
s and the same happens for INT and
because this is this is the case then i
can say that I Arsen T is a triad the
same thing goes for tried the tripod
query which is put a little different
though it's not as obvious as the
triangle Perry but here the same thing
happens and we are connected regardless
of Z a ser kanata regards of Y and so on
so forth and then we have the ABC as a
is a triad for that query as you could I
don't know if you have noticed but there
is a close connection here with the
reduction we did from the triangle query
to the tripod query if that's what we
use to show that if a query has a triad
then it's going to be np-complete so we
can generalize that proof that we duck
shin that we have from the triangle
query to the tripod query for any query
that has a triad then the next question
of course is like oh and important
remarks that's very easy to check that
like even any queries just like a reach
ability problem of the hypergraph but
then okay not all the queries have tried
right like you can think that what
happens for to their complex in that
case so let's first look into the very
obvious no triad case which would be
what we call a linear query so we call
this query linear here because we can
draw the hypergraph and the hyper edges
are like convex but there is also
another like definition that is
equivalent that is like I could just
arrange the atoms in the choir in a way
that the variables all occur together if
you remember the triangle worry I
couldn't do that because every time I
try to put some variables together some
other variable appear like separated and
one thing that we know is like proved by
melia we're all in 2010 is that for self
joint frequency of queries if the query
is linear then the resilience of the
square is going to be in polynomial time
and it's like a very nice reduction to
network flow i can give an aquarian
really the basic can construct is not
like this graph and the network flowing
that the max cut in that graph is going
to be the minimum contingent set for the
query but you know let's look into like
an interesting example so the square e
it's almost the triangle query but it's
called a rat query and only difference
now you have this particular a here so
we have this ax 0 you might have you
know imagined that they now I have
something similar happen here that what
happens for the tripod query right when
i had the domination going on and indeed
the resilience of this query is
polynomial time and as i mentioned what
happens here is that a dominates TNR
let's just go back here i have that dino
a donates are and they don't HT because
they contain X and therefore from what I
said before are empty are effective
exogenous therefore I don't have left
three endogenous like atoms to create
the triad so this is like near not
linear sorry it's polynomial but that
doesn't say exactly how can I show that
this is actually polynomial and the
jess is that if I cannot find a triad in
this query after I found all the topples
of all the relations that are exogenous
I can actually reduce this query to a
query that is linear and therefore
because we know that for Linea queries
the resilience its polynomial it's going
to be polynomial for that query as well
so that leads us to our first economy
result which means which says that for
some time free conjunctive queries given
its normal form if its normal form have
tried that the problem is np-complete
and if it does not have a try it it's
important no meal time and like there is
nothing in between so from here what we
also did was to consider functional
dependencies to see how that could
change the problem so just an example
here for the like tripod query again
this is a database the database and if I
now consider this functional dependency
on w meaning that ax determine why the
database that I had before no longer
it's valid because it it does not
satisfy the condition that ax needs to
determine why so as one can think
functional dependencies will constrain
the databases you can consider and as
usual if I'm constraining my iPad I can
ask again is this going to make my
problem easier the main question for us
was are there going to be any NP
complete problems remain or is in NP
complete query going to become
polynomial and also how can we capture
this restriction that the functional
dependency implies so what we do here is
that we transform the query based on
this data under the functional
dependencies and we do that by what we
call industry rights so I'm just going
to show in this example that we have so
here we have the tripod query and we
have the function dependency Exeter
means why so what we can do is that even
that everything join
is if I know that X determines why here
on w I also know that for the purpose of
the tuples are join it's going to be
through here for the acts that occurs in
a so I can just up meant my relation
with this extra column and say that a
also contains why now and as you saw
before if I look just to this query what
I can say is that be now dominates a so
i actually have just to B and C as the
the endogenous relations and indeed the
problem now and then so this is the
first step and then the second step
would be thus make this do does the
industry right capture completely the
restriction of the functional dependency
because of course this is not the same
problem as this right if I consider the
function dependency might not
necessarily because it's a restriction
of database may not me that when i get
rid of that then i can just look to any
database but actually we were able to
prove that we can just get rid of that
and indeed for this case here the you
know resilience of the tripod perry with
this particular functional dependencies
polynomial time and i'm going to be a
little like if like so that's how we
define the industry right so i have a
query and i have a set of functional
dependencies and I'm gonna add variables
like the variables that occurred on the
right hand side of the function
dependency to each atom that have all of
the square of the variables on the left
hand side and I did that until i reach a
fixed point and i can can do anything
anymore and that query we call the
clothes query so if i have a query and a
set of action dependencies after I apply
all the Possible's in those rewrite I
hoping to star and that's what we call
the clothes query in what we show is
that all those three problems are
equivalent so if i have the functional
dependency and apply the industry rights
these are equivalent and again the thing
that is a little more tricky is ok we
can actually get rid of the function
dependencies meaning that the industry
right completely captures the
restrictions that the function
dependency imposes on the database
which leads us to the second dichotomy
theorem which just says that after I
have done all the signs after I have
apply all the industry rights to my
query I can just use the same thing from
before so if my clothes query has a
triad then the problems NP complete and
if it does not have then it is in
polynomial time so one of the
interesting things that came up into
this work is this notion of triads that
we are trying to figure if it is like
robust enough to deal with other
problems as well I didn't mention this
before but the problem of resilience is
very closely related with vertex cover
hypergraphs because if you give me a
query and you give me a database I can
construct this new hyper graph and then
the vertex cover there is going to be
the contingency side so there is
expression also if can we find something
about you know triads and hypergraphs
and try to make a connection over there
but a fartlek apart from that we have
some other like open problems so as i
mentioned we're not dealing with self
joints so far so we're not like thinking
of queries like the VX y XY dy query and
that's what we actually been working on
and I can tell you that the Triads can
say something about those queries as
well so we can actually characterize
some hard like instances when you think
of in terms of triads but it doesn't
seem to be enough yet it might be but we
haven't been able to find in particular
because the we don't know exactly how
the notion of domination goes when we
have self joints and also linear queries
don't necessarily like are easy me
actually the disk worry that i have like
showed in the beginning it's an example
of that we also would like to look into
the deletion propagation which is
equivalent to this problem but then you
have to
I'm gonna say two flavors of the
deletion propagation problem so we have
a flavor we're with the deletion
propagation problem just like to say the
same idea like i have a veal and i want
to change the view i want to delete some
typos from the view in order to do that
I need to delete some type of from the
database and I don't know either what is
the minimum number of topics or the
database now that should delete the top
of from the view or what is the knot
which tapas from the database i delete
another to minimize the side effects on
the view like if i want to digest like I
want to do I want to preserve the view I
want to preserve the source the database
so our case is the case where we want to
preserve the source there is some work
done already on the case of like wanting
to preserve the view but also they just
deal with like self join free queries me
they do exactly not exactly but yeah
they cover the same queries that we
cover here but i also don't know what to
do with like self joint and like in step
ahead even given that we have a
dichotomy as you know it's not it's an
interesting phenomenon like-for-like
problems even that we have the dichotomy
in PP you'll be interesting to see if we
still can find like the more we
stratified collection of classes within
be like basically any particular ac0 or
something like that we should be very
interesting for databases and that's it
thank
so I just wanted to ask you about the
work of human filth and others you
mentioned there is another favorite by
human felt a bond right and good and
they are they first of all under to
program uses very equivalent but is
there equivalent why don't you engage
that I go to be hearing from them so
they are not equivalent to I'm saying
that so the resilience problem is
equivalent to the deletion propagation
with the source side effect and they
focus on the view side effect so they
are like they want to minimize how many
because imagine this I'm if I'm deleting
a topic from the view it doesn't
necessarily mean that i will have a
solution that is free from sided site so
i might delete other like tuples from
the view that I didn't want you they
want to minimize that and what we do
like looking to minimizes the changes on
the database so it's like they are not
equivalent problems I thought their
dichotomy doesn't apply to us another
than compliance asking whether is a
duction when they call them to the
ossicles like you do have a patient but
ok sorry I did yeah your question I
would watch the forum in the paper
that's vldb 2013 I think they could a
dichotomous yes yes I caught on yours
that you are dealing with an
optimization stuff and for the NP k NP
hard cases they look at approximation
property yes and already we show your
first exam involve the vertex comment
it's constant abuse that I gotta me
clear about the approximations we don't
have like yet but definitely something
you will be looking to it and yeah we
have strong in particular because our
problem is very related to the vertex
solving hypergraphs we do think that we
could be able to find like interesting
approximations I don't know it because
in this case he has like hatch
approximate and like things that they
actually can approximate and then the
polynomial case yeah yeah I don't my
sister that we don't have a tracker on
here but I do have like interesting like
approximations
was a further questions see every I just
have a comment for maybe maybe for the
rest of the meeting if they're really
with the self they're really interesting
issues in the self join one that you're
working on now because you enough time
to mention them but they're there there
are some symmetry issues this user both
least blogger bootcamp and the previous
web shop called they all of these
databases exactly this difficulty of
self Giants oh ok it comes up in the
dichotomy theorem short probably see
that this is that much harder if you get
yourself joints and when it comes to
inconsistent databases so far we have
dichotomy theorem for consistently
answering or very consistent databases
so the presence of self sorry thank you
again